some hospitals in states where
coronavirus cases are surging
are now running out of beds and many
doctors and nurses who watched covet 19
hit the new york city area very hard
are now concerned about what's next for
their communities our senior medical
correspondent dr tara narula spoke to
frontline medical workers in california
texas alabama and florida about their
fears
we started out a few weeks ago with
around 130 patients and it's
gone up to about 380 patients in the
last two weeks
were you prepared uh we were we had
what i like to call the gift of time i
remember really distinctly when the
outbreak happened in new york city
we were all in our ers down here in
texas we started
preparing we started gathering ppe
and we were waiting for a front that we
felt would come
and then wham it hit with after memorial
day
we're very stressed i've never seen
surges like this
i've never seen this many this critical
this many patients this critical i've
never seen the nurses work so much over
time
you think maybe okay it'll start to
trend downward but then you get a new
set of numbers the next day and they're
either steady or they're increasing
what are you hearing from some of your
colleagues where you are at in
california
in terms of their level of concern or
fear
i think the real fear people have now is
nobody wants to be in a situation
where your resources are overwhelmed and
you know there's things you could have
done
to help people and save their life or
decrease their long-term complications
you start to become a little more
concerned and anxious
every single day when you have a little
bit of i can't find a bed for my icu
patient or i can't find
a bed for a patient who's admitted
that's when you start to feel a little
bit of the pressure
and the anxiety that oh man is this the
tipping point i wear a mask
13 14 hours a day it's not
that comfortable it's much better than
the alternative
people that you know are thinking that
masks don't matter and that coronavirus
isn't real or it's not as big of a
problem as it is
it kind of hurts actually we know how to
mitigate and decrease the harm and
that's by wearing masks it's really kind
of like
not running a red light i mean we don't
run a red light so we don't get an
accident and so we don't create an
accident for other people it's very
scary
for all of us but we have a passion
nurses have a passion to care for people
and i think that's just kicking into
overdrive
this is seeming a lot more like a
marathon
and it certainly takes a toll on
everybody who's involved normally i
would get in the car after a shift
you know radio up loud i'm happy to be
off nowadays i ride home a lot of times
in silence
just processing the things that i've
seen i just
pray that i continue to be able to do
what i do and help as many people as
possible
and dr taran nerula joins us now dr
narula that's a powerful piece there i
remember
in the early outbreak here in new york
medical workers were afraid of going
home and infecting their
families is that still a concern in
these other states
it is tony and as you mentioned it's
been one of the biggest fears of health
care workers throughout this pandemic
and you can imagine these are the
individuals who've really borne witness
to this tragedy the fact that it doesn't
discriminate it kills the young the old
the people have been dying in the icu
alone having to say goodbye on an ipad
and that creates as one doctor wrote
memories i wish i didn't have
and when doctors are in medical school
they put on that white coat and they
take that oath
they know they're going to be
sacrificing physically emotionally
mentally for the rest of their life
but what they don't think they're going
to have to do is sacrifice or jeopardize
the health of their family and loved
ones and that is the impossible decision
and choice that many of them
find themselves in right now yeah are
there lessons at least that these other
states can take from the experience here
in new york
absolutely and many of the doctors and
healthcare workers we spoke to said that
they had
as you saw in the piece the gift of time
and experience time to understand how
this virus works
how to ventilate patients what drugs
might work what kind of staffing and
equipment they'll need
but many of them said that all of that
time and experience only goes so far
if you have a failure or a lack of
leadership in your state or at the
federal government level if you have
individuals who are not wearing masks
and taking this seriously
we asked one doctor what is one image
that you wish people would remember
and she said it's the fear in a
patient's eyes when they're looking at
me not knowing
if the treatment intervention i'm going
to give them is going to work
imagine that that fear in that face is
your mother your sister your child your
grandparent maybe then she said
people will take this seriously all
right we can hope dr taran arula thank
you very much